what if you were asked to find the HC f
and LCM of 16 and 20 you have two
options either you find the HC f and LCM
separately or we find them together of
course we will find them together all we
need to do is use the common division
method of finding the LCM in the first
step we write the numbers separated by a
comma and then draw an l-shape line like
this then we look for a common factor of
the two numbers and write it here 2 is
common factor of both the numbers then
we write the quotients underneath 2
times 8 is 16 and 2 times 10 is 20 since
these numbers are not co-prime we go
back to the second step and continue the
process they have two as the common
factor and 2 times 4 is 8 2 times 5 is
10 we stop here since 4 & 5 are co-prime
numbers they have no common factors
except 1 the product of the numbers in
this l-shape gives us the LCM of the two
numbers the LCM equals 2 times 2 times 4
times 5 that is 4 multiplied by 20 which
equals 80 yes but how does this give us
the HCF well the product of the factors
on the Left gives us the HCF hence the
HCF will equal 2 times 2 which is 4 this
is the HCF of 16 and 20 so you can see
that just this one method gave us the
HCF as well as the LCM of two numbers
but we also have to note
that this works only for two numbers
there is another interesting concept
above the HCF and the LCM of two numbers
first let's find the product of the LCM
and the HCF LCM is 80 and the HCF is for
the product will be 80 times 4 which
equals 320 now let's find the product of
the two numbers it will be 16 times 20
which equals 320 this will always be
true for any two given numbers the
product of the LCM and HCF will be equal
to the product of the two given numbers
you